four thousand police and soldiers raided
one of Ecuador's most infamous prisons
in the port city of guayakil to detain
Adolfo Macias Elias fito
the leader of the country's most
powerful drug Syndicate the tornadoes is
serving a 32-year sentence for murder
and was taken to a nearby Maximum
Security Prison on the orders of
president guillermolasso
authorities say they suspect fito's
involvement in Thursday's murder of
presidential candidate Fernando
villavicencio who had recently received
death threats from him
hours after the raid and from the very
same prison members of the tornado gang
posted this video on social networks
warning the president not harm their
leader for the well-being of Ecuador
thousands of people will die straining
the people of Ecuador with blood because
of your bad decisions what
else Widow accused the government of
holding back information
the state is directly responsible for
the murder of my husband the state still
has to give many answers about
everything that happened his personal
guards did not do their job
experts in organized crimes say it has
penetrated the highest levels of the
Ecuadorian State
we have to ask ourselves are the
intelligence Services unable to identify
this penetration in all the institutions
of power or do they know about it but do
nothing
I believe it's the former
the president who called Snap elections
for next Sunday in a bid to avoid an
impeachment trial says he's doing all he
can
but the Detention of an already
imprisoned drug lord will not be enough
to ease people's fears ecuadorians are
demanding that the government guarantee
security not just for candidates but for
voters and in fact for the entire
electoral process
process that has raised questions about
the ability of any candidate to confront
the seemingly uncontrollable expansion
of crime and Corruption
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Quito Ecuador
well earlier my colleague Kerry Johnston
spoke to Manuel